The Joe Rogan Experience you know that's
what Bob Lazar thinks that spaceship
that he worked on was made with he
thinks it was somehow 3D printed because
it has no seams
you pay attention to UFO [__] no good
for you no but I know you do something
I'm gonna ask because I
it's like this [__] just there's so much
[__] that's just coming out now I don't
I don't understand though
what's the motive behind it just
randomly coming out now yeah I'm super
suspicious so what's the place area um
51 Area 51 yeah like um
I'm assuming that [__] has been real
that's real yeah but Area 51 was used
for
all sorts of training purposes they had
all sorts of uh programs they were
running out there I think that's where
they developed the B-52 is that where
they developed it nearing 51 they
developed a bunch of different uh
military Technologies out there so
nothing was true about the the we don't
know we don't know it's all just
guessing about whether or not they're
working on UFOs but they were definitely
work on other stuff too it's a
legitimate military base so you think
these videos real that's that's coming
out are you thinking I think the videos
are real
what they're filming I don't know what
that is it could be that it's some super
sophisticated U.S controlled drone that
um was built in some sort of
a program that's top secret and it has
some new super sophisticated uh
propulsion system that they don't want
us to know about and so they pretend
it's coming from another world and they
say oh these are off-world crafts
exhibiting Behavior that's impossible to
replicate in America I wonder I wonder
because if they're talking about it like
that they're literally saying off world
like sure
boy I get suspicious I get suspicious
because they're not super honest about
anything no why would they be honest
about spaceships they'll and then it
just randomly happens now you know yeah
it's well it's another nice distraction
it gets people all excited the other
[__] fake little Mexican UFO baby
they're doubling down no they're not I
took it this is from the MRI yesterday
they took they said it's one skeleton
what are they doing like they're trying
other like American scientists are
saying well then a lot of people test
samples of it or something but well did
they have images from the MRI I mean I
don't know that they showed those actual
images but the doctor that took it yes
they were here they belong to a single
skeleton that has not been joined to
other pieces interesting footage from
the team carrying out the tests
shows one of the bodies bearing in
elongated head a small upturned nose and
two slanted eyes the subjects look tiny
when held up by the doctors examining
the watching for the watching
journalists and then this muscles like
this person says that I think it's the
doctor has claimed that he talks to the
version of Guadalupe and the
extraterrestrials will not talk to her
like to talk to him because she doesn't
believe in them
maybe he does drugs laughs
maybe he's telling the truth maybe he
did talk to the Virgin of Guadalupe
um so that's what it's supposed to be I
want to see what those images look like
they don't have them you ever notice
that none of the images be clear yeah oh
[__] like that we really want to see
yeah it's a real problem
I talked to this one guy Christopher
Mellon he used to be an intelligence
agent and he said that they do have
clear footage it just hasn't been leaked
but that he's aware of it and some of
it's pretty mind-blowing he said
I don't know show me until this until I
see it I don't know man I feel like a
dummy because I want to believe in it so
bad that's the problem
because it's so fun
you know the idea of spaceships coming
here for another galaxy I don't know I
don't know how fun especially if they
ain't friendly well if they weren't
friendly we'd already be [__] right
I mean if they've been coming here
forever supposedly and they haven't
heard us yet
we're probably okay
you know I think they're probably
observing us they're probably if they
are coming from another world they're
probably making sure we don't blow
ourselves up
they're probably realizing that we're at
this convergence of the evolution of the
biology and then science and technology
and its abilities that far surpass like
the speed that the biology evolves like
the biology evolves very slowly
relatively compared to these computers
the things that they're able to do these
spaceships and the flying cars it's like
we have so much ability now and we're
still the same kind of creature
we're still humans you know but now we
have this insane ability to blow up a
whole country like we have nuclear bombs
we're all pointing them at each other
and there's enough to wipe out the whole
world like if I was an alien I'd be like
let's keep an eye on these crazy [__]
you know these people are wild
let's keep an eye on them
yeah yeah definitely uh
I'm gonna keep my distance from that
yeah yeah I don't want to fly tomorrow I
don't want to none of that [__] I just
man live my life
yeah it's gonna be a long time before
people get comfortable moving to Mars
yeah I don't know how long that's gonna
be but but that's a [__] commitment
then they have somebody recently go are
they letting people go now no they
haven't let people go yet they've uh
sent drones
so they have the Mars rover that goes
around on Mars but that's just a robot
but the idea
is to have people on Mars I think
didn't Elon Say by like 20 35 or
something like that he wants man trip to
Mars that's crazy you keep saying his
name he's the only to see doing whatever
the [__] you want to do yeah he's a wild
fella